um
hi everyone welcome to uh the homeroom
live stream sal here from khan academy
uh so we're gonna have a disappointing
guest today it is myself
so we're gonna be doing an ask me
anything so if you have questions about
literally anything i i i hope to be
surprised by your questions uh within
within bounds
uh put them on the message boards
wherever you're watching this whether
it's facebook youtube or
maybe someplace else uh but before we
jump into the ask me
anything i'll give my standard
announcement first of all reminder that
khan academy is a not-for-profit
organization we can only exist through
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so
please go to khan academy.org donate
i also want to give a special shout out
to several organizations that have
supported khan academy especially
through this coveted crisis there's many
others
more of the name you go to our
supporters page but especially
as we're going into the coveted crisis
we were already running at a deficit
and you can imagine our expenses have
only gone up uh with our server costs
and us trying to accelerate a whole
series
of content and programs so special
thanks to bank of america google.org
att fastly novartis and many others who
over the years have supported khan
academy
many of you all without that support it
wouldn't be possible and we could we are
continuing to run
at a deficit especially for next year so
uh please
think about making a donation everything
makes a difference uh so with that
uh i'm excited to answer questions and
so the team has already started
surfacing some questions i think a few
of these might have been from from
before so let's see
uh these are all really good questions
so the first question from youtube
vivek desai how do we level the playing
field
in low funded schools it's a good
question
uh you know i think arguably khan
academy with a
mission of free world-class education
for anyone anywhere
it's implicit that we are trying to
level the playing field especially for
folks
uh who are lo who are low income or
might be
attending schools with less resources or
maybe don't even have access to schools
and so one theory of action for us is
that you know hopefully folks will be
able to leverage
things like khan academy and it's not
just students using it on their own but
you know half of our usage is teachers
using khan academy as part of their
classrooms where students are able to
work on khan academy exercises sometimes
aligned
to the student teachers lessons
sometimes the teachers students are
doing it their own time and pace
and teachers are able to then understand
where all of their kids are
and then support them more inside of the
classroom
uh we we've seen a lot of efficacy
studies that that could make a huge
difference
now clearly in order to use khan academy
that way there are some prerequisite
things that have to exist
internet connections for short the
school devices at the school
ideally would be at the home and school
we're seeing that a lot with kovid
but you know this is one area that we
think we can help
level start help leveling the playing
field i don't want to pretend like it's
a simple solution and that you can just
you know snap your fingers and that
everything is is perfect
um some of y'all know i have another
skunk work project it is not a part of
khan academy it's
it's actually i'm incorporating it as we
speak as a separate non-for-profit
called schoolhouse.world to try to get
more folks access to tutoring
as well uh so that you know not only can
you get all the practice the feedback
the video supports the instructional
supports
the teacher supports through khan
academy but you can also become
you know connect to other people and
really become part of a community of
learning
is really my dream uh because in in both
of those cases learning is not bound by
time or space
learning can meet you where you are and
then you know the zip code that you live
in or the income of your family
or the neighborhood you live in should
matter less unfortunately it'll always
probably play a factor but it will
hopefully matter
a lot less see there's
a question let's see jim sugar brown
from facebook asks sal how do you see
the future of education and learning can
you differentiate
between the two so that's a big question
i i like that you're trying you know
you're saying well
the difference between education and
learning you know when i at least
imagine education i imagine
all of the things that the education
system does there's a learning
component of it and we're traditionally
thinking of like core academic skills
then there is a socialization you know a
lot of us
we learn to kind of work with others in
many years of school
and then another thing that the school
system does is kind of a credentialing
aspect to it um i think we're learning
with covid also the school system
especially for younger kids provides a
child care function but it's
it's really academics credentialing
socialization
and kind of care of of kids and and
there's other supports that the
education system does as well things
like lunch programs and
other other social supports you know
the learning you could consider is
broader it's a lot of that
uh but you could you know when i imagine
learning i imagine
you know me using youtube to figure out
how to fix my toilet which i've done
several times uh especially during covid
uh or you know just learning how to how
to play guitar
and arguably some of these things could
be part of the education system as well
but i think in in either case we're
going to be moving to a world
where there's going to be far more paths
that people can take and they're going
to be far more customizable to the needs
of the individual
and as these as the paths that you can
take become
more personalized and more diverse
then there's going to be more universal
ways of proving what you know creating a
signal
to you know you could call it a
credential so that other people can
understand
uh what you are capable of uh i also
think you're going to see you know i've
talked about the schoolhouse.world
project which is separate from khan
academy
but i also think you're going to see
more mechanisms where
communities of people are going to be
able to support each other in kind of a
very
grassroots way which i think could be
very powerful you know i think
historically the last 200 years
education and learning has been a very
centralized affair uh it's it's been you
know
a couple of folks get together in a room
i mean famously the courses that you
many of y'all learned or we all learned
in high school were determined by 10
university presidents in 1890
uh and then there's the community of 10.
you could look it up
uh and so that's obviously as
centralized as it gets
so i think i think you're going to start
seeing a lot more diversity in pats but
you're going to start seeing
much stronger ways that you can prove
what you know and really community being
a very powerful way to learn
so there's uh from youtube smartbear
asking sal can you tell me how did you
make it to where you are right now
founder and ceo of khan academy i
often times wonder that myself
um you know i i think growing up
i think we all have this kind of angst
and frankly the answer hasn't gone away
yet that you know we have one life
how do we make make it count or how do
we make it worth something
uh and you know we can debate what it
means to count or what it means to work
something my
i believe that i've evolved over over
time you know when i was a teenager
uh or in my early 20s i think you know i
i imagined counting making a dent in the
universe being all about
kind of external uh whatever
impact external you know whether it's
discover a new
you know drug that could like cure
disease or
um impacting people in a certain way or
you know
i i'd have to admit especially early and
probably even now but early in my life
i probably was motivated to saying hey i
would i would like to be able to you
know i grew up not so
wealthy in fact you know my mom i think
made sixteen thousand dollars in
1994 which was the year that i had to
help her fill out the taxes to get
financial aid for college so we didn't
have a lot of money
um you know she was making roughly
minimum wage uh so there was in me
a lot of i would say a fire in my belly
to try to
be financially comfortable uh and not
have to kind of go through some of the
financial uncertainties
that we had growing up um and you know
so i i did what i thought would would
make sense there but i i never like was
just one of these kids that was just
like okay what do i need to do to get a
job
you know what's going to be on the test
let me just ace it i i naturally i mean
i think y'all can tell my personality
no matter how pragmatic i try to be my i
do a lot of daydreaming
my personality tends to wander into the
into the uh
i don't know what you would call it uh
the the aspirational the delusional
uh the imagining what the world could be
uh
and and i've often i i've and i've often
felt this angst that like you know we
only have so many decades on this planet
let's make it interesting you know let's
not just try to let's just not try to go
through the mold that everyone else has
there's certain things we have to do to
be able to pay the bills and you know
hopefully get a house and pay off your
debts etc etc support your family
uh but you know we got let's make it
interesting too
um so anyway you know college uh
i i tried to do my best that you know to
kind of get a good job i had a good job
when
you know in 1998 came out here to
uh silicon valley worked with oracle as
a product manager
it was a good job had a really good boss
name thomas curry and he's actually
quite known in tech circles now he runs
all of google cloud but i i was one of
the first people he ever hired he
he was in his early 30s at the time uh
and then
you know it was startup it was the
dot-com mania
i went and joined a startup that was a
great experience
but then you know the nasdaq started to
tank and i said i should i should take
some shelter in business school and try
to figure out what i want to do with
with my life
i i also say you know i went to business
school because i was lonely
and and i had this theory that in boston
there were a lot more students and i
could probably find
you know a life partner um and so i went
back to boston for
this goes true both things happened i
figured out what i at least what i want
to do
career-wise for my next stage and i met
my now
actually i met my wife back in 1997 and
you know i
i had always uh aspired to get to know
her better for many years and but then
in 2002
i got i i was successful and um
she hasn't uh she she she hasn't figured
it out just yet that
you know i've i've definitely been the
winner on this uh
situation but the um anyway i i'm
probably going into more
more of my biography than you're asking
but you know it was kind of it's been
like this kind of uh
very uh circuitous path but it was i
think many of y'all know you could find
videos on
youtube and other places of me telling
the khan academy genesis story but it
was really 2004 i was a
analyst at a hedge fund cousin needed
help and but in the back of my mind had
always thought about that
you know maybe technology could be a
really powerful tool to scalably help a
lot of folks
uh and so that's when i started tutoring
cousins
word spread that free tutoring was going
on that i started tutoring more cousins
i started making software for them
videos for them people who are not my
cousins like yourselves were starting to
use them
by 2009 i had trouble focusing on my day
job
2000 uh so i quit it we were living off
of savings
that was scary i mean you know you're
asking how do i get here
you know yeah you're going to have these
moments of
having to kind of jump into scary things
and you're going to question yourself
and you're going to
you know that year that khan academy had
no funding and i was living off of
savings our first child had been born it
was creating all sorts of stresses i was
waking up in the middle of the night you
know what it had done to my family what
what what i had done to my career so
you're gonna have your moments of
self-doubt
um but then you know it's been uh we
eventually got funding and we've been on
this journey and you know
and and even now i have my moments where
i'm super excited i'm like wow we're
going to be in a position one day to
impact billions of folks
but then there's days where i feel that
you know something went wrong or
you know i thought we were going to get
some funding for for some big project
and it doesn't happen or
you know we were trying to build
something and we realized that you know
there's
there's mold in the attic so to speak
and it's gonna take more work than we
expected
uh but you try to power through those
things uh because because
you know it's it's it's i consider
myself very fortunate to be able to work
on a mission
uh like this and to uh be able to work
with really great people you know the
khan academy team's over 200 folks now
we've had thousands of volunteers
uh so it's a you know it's if you get to
work on something that's intellectually
interesting
can make a dent in the world and you're
able to work with other really good
people
you know i i don't think you can really
ask for for more than that so uh you
know i hope to be able to do this until
the day i die which is hopefully
hopefully many decades from now
so um rude rene
mandal from facebook if you were not in
this profession what other profession
would you go for
so you know some of if i'm honest you
know before this i was an analyst at a
hedge fund
um so maybe i would still be an analyst
at a hedge fund although even while i
was an analyst at a hedge fund
and i know some of you are wondering
what is a hedge fund a hedge fund is
essentially an investment management
company
think of a mutual fund the difference
between a mutual fund and a hedge fund
is
a mutual fund is heavily regulated but
because
it's heavily regulated they're allowed
to market more broadly but they're
essentially mutual funds buy stocks a
basket of stocks and
you know you using your money and if it
does well it does well
hedge funds also are buying or selling
a basket of things but they're less
regulated so they can buy other things
they can buy
options they can buy debt they can buy
they could even buy you know they could
buy literally
literally anything and they can they can
do more exotic
things like you know futures or they
could short things or
uh you know have options so
so uh i i was already in that industry
there's
definitely a world where i would have
stayed in it but i used to tell my
friends my rationalization i did enjoy
that work it was very
intellectually stimulating and it it
paid well uh
was uh i said i would do this until
i i could be i could i could kind of do
whatever i wanted and then i would start
at school one day so i did always have
these
dreams but obviously the the school
happened in a different way through khan
academy it happened
well before i was uh able to do it able
to do it on my
on my own uh you know i think in
alternate realities
i you know i would i would i probably
could have you know
maybe been a science fiction author that
i'd like to believe that who knows
um anyway who knows but i probably would
have would have stayed in the hedge fund
world
and then eventually transitioned to
becoming some type of an educator i
think
so from youtube akshay murthy is asking
what type of global impact could khan
academy have and why does my school not
use khan academy is there a way to make
khan academy more widespread
well actually you're asking three
questions that i'm constantly asking
myself and
the team at god academy we're constantly
asking ourselves what kind of global
impact can we have
why is it that school using khan academy
and how is there a way to make it more
widespread
uh you know the global impact we could
have
i i you know we we have over 100 million
registered users
now we have about 30 million folks come
to the site every month and do some type
of a learning action
it's a smaller subset of that that is
doing it at like a very regular
rate but obviously there's hundreds of
millions arguably billions of students
in the world who could benefit from khan
academy and there's 46 translation
projects
going on of khan academy uh so you know
my
genuine dream is if we're talking five
ten years from now that
let's say 10 years from now there's
billions of folks who are using khan
academy
it's their lifeline to get practice to
get feedback to learn a lot of things
ideally they're able to use it in
conjunction with schools
it's able to unlock a kind of true
personalization in a school setting
teachers jobs get easier they can use
that data they don't have to like
you know assign things and grade things
and all of that can happen automatically
and they get really good data so that
when they get together with students
they're able to dig a little bit deeper
motivate them unstick them do projects
do simulations etc
and and i hope you know because it's at
a scale of billions
we're able to you know move the dial on
on
whatever you want to call it impact
scores test scores outcomes
uh on the scale of nations or on the
scale internationally so that you know
in
10 20 years people like could you
imagine there used to be a day where 70
of folks had to take remedial math in
college or this large chunk of humanity
thought that algebra was difficult now
everyone knows how to do it it's like
you know it's it's just a basic skill
that all of humanity has
and i don't think you know and we're not
our vision is not just a stop at math
you know we already have a lot of
science and and social sciences and
humanities on khan academy
i think math is where we're strongest
now uh probably followed by science
and we're actually hoping to actually
accelerate a lot of the science over the
next
few years but eventually we want to
cover all core academic subjects
and we want to wait create ways for
people to prove what they know to the
broader world so
it's a big vision you know why is your
school not using it
i don't know i think there's going to be
a video version of this you should you
should
you know akshay school please use khan
academy we'll want to make life easier
for you
um and and we think your kids will enjoy
it your teachers will enjoy we're here
to support all of you teachers
so akshay school think about it uh and
then how do we make it more widespread i
think we just have
you know on khan academy side we just
have to make sure we understand the
needs of teachers
and keep improving on the the software
the content for them
the use cases so we can support more and
more of what they're doing
and then we just have to work with all
of y'all in the world and corporations
whoever else
to spread the word you know i think a
lot of people are like they don't they
don't fully understand that
one we're not for profit we're not
selling anything everything we're doing
is philanthropically supported and free
uh so and it's frankly the most
efficacious thing out there some people
think that if something is free it must
not be as good as the expensive thing
but if you you know do your research if
you look at efficacy data
if you look at if you just talk to
people who've used khan academy versus
other tools
i think this is one of those worlds
where i i'd like to believe that the
best things in the world truly truly are
free so help us spread the word
so there
so far from youtube prussian beau is
asking is kind of going to be primarily
for homeschooling or just for practice
well it can be used for either of those
things we know a lot of homeschoolers
around the world
lean quite heavily on khan academy
especially for math and science but in
other subjects as well and things like
our sat prep which goes into math
reading and writing
we have khan academy kids which is math
social emotional learning
reading and writing but it's not just
for homeschooling
it can be used for practice in fact
that's where we put most of our
resources to have kind of a
practice platform where you can get
especially in math and we're starting to
have in science and other subjects
prac as much practice as you need on all
the core skills with game mechanics and
make sure you retain it that you can
really
master the content but we also have
video supports and hints and articles
that you so you're not just doing that
practice in a vacuum if you're having
difficulty
you get more supports and if you're
doing in a classroom context your
teachers or
actually it could even be your parents
could be your coach can understand what
more help you need
so that you don't get stuck with just
the supports that that we're able to
provide like the video so
uh we like to see it as all of the above
from youtube maheka to prani hey sal
you always talk about how you had a huge
passion for learning even as a student
have you along the path of your
education ever strayed from this passion
how did you deal with such slumps you
know i've always
i've never i guess not been curious
um i've never i've never like had a
moment where i'm like
oh learning's no fun i don't want to
understand this mystery called life
no i've never been there i've never been
there uh i have been in places where
i've been
demoralized feeling insecure wondering
whether
like everything i've ever done has been
pointless so i've been definitely
i've definitely had those moments um and
i've definitely had moments
where i'm just stressed about something
is something going to turn out the way i
want it to be
or you know i'm working with a colleague
or i have a manager or boss where i'm
like oh i don't think they understand
what i did or
i don't think they like me or you know i
we we all go through emotions like that
um the way that the way
i deal with the what you could call
slumps
is i remind myself you know once you
have a little bit of a
hindsight of all your past lumps and i
got to believe mahika you have your
slumps you've had your slumps
and if you look back on your slumps you
know some of these things that in the
day that you were completely stressed
about it
you're like oh it's the end of the world
i can't believe this happened and
someone said this or whatever
this is going to happen often times a
week later
like you you even forget what that thing
was
and even if something is something more
serious that has longer lasting
implications you know i remind ourselves
we have
a finite number of years on this planet
this planet is a speck in this broad
universe
you know even these things that we
identify very very strongly with you
know i
i identify very very strongly with the
name sal khan i identify very strongly
with
this you know appearance with um my role
and with my family
uh with society my job with chronic
these are all things that i
identify very strongly with you know my
my ego and like you know the technical
ego not the like
braggadocious ego but like my identity
ego persona whatever you want to call it
it is connected to all of these things
and the times where
you often feel the most stress is when
you feel that some aspect of your
persona
some aspect of your identity is under
threat you know my identity i think i'm
an honest person
why does that person think that i'm not
honest or you know i think i did a good
job i
i think i'm capable but maybe someone
else doesn't think so or
you know my persona is tied to the
success of khan academy but
wow i just got a data point that maybe
kanekalon is going to have trouble in
that area
that causes stress and the way i get
through that is one reminding myself
that i
a lot of these things resolve on their
own usually for the best
but even if it resolves in a negative
way to not tie my
my my who i am my identity to that
outcome
uh because that's not going to benefit
anyone that's just going to make me
miserable it's not going to change the
outcome
uh you know in in eastern philosophy and
vedic philosophy there's this notion of
of southwick action which is do what you
think is right but don't get caught up
in the outcome
don't don't do something because you
think it's going to have a a great
outcome or because you're
afraid that if you don't do it you're
going to have a negative outcome do it
because you think it's
because you think it's the right thing
to do and then the chips fall where they
do
and if you do that it can it's actually
very very liberating you do what you
think is right but you won't obsess
about it you won't regret things as much
and you'll just be a happier person and
you'll just be more open to kind of just
you know positive things out there
another thing i'd recommend i've talked
about this before is i do a lot of
uh meditation um and you know i think
the benefit of meditation which is
really just
sitting quietly and giving your your
mind a chance to
to steal itself you know most of us our
minds are constantly jumping it's like a
circus in there you're like
oh i got to pay my taxes um am i
watering my lawn
enough you know do i need to you know
do my laundry um i wonder if i'm going
to be able to fundraise enough for that
effort on khan academy
um is that team not aligned i need to
talk to this person we have this
constant narrative
in our heads and and sometimes it's just
like completely
random stuff like if a bear attacked me
what would i do it's
you know there's all sorts of stuff that
is is going on at least in my mind but
when you meditate
um you you kind of say okay self
give yourself a chance to just pause
don't be worried about what's happened
in the past what's in the future just be
in the present
and just let your mind just just be in
awareness don't think about i am sal
don't think about i hope khan academy
succeeds don't think about what people
think of you or all of the chores you
have to do
just be there aware and at first it's
difficult but once you start doing it
regularly
you'll actually find that it's
incredibly peaceful and it's incredibly
liberating
and it kind of stays with you the rest
of the day
where if if something happens that would
traditionally have triggered you
or make you feel off off balance you'll
be like you know what
this is just happening in material
reality this isn't really
affecting my true self so so you know
you do what's right
if you have to correct something if you
have to say something say it but then
don't get
caught up in it but anyway i give you a
longer i kind of ended up giving you
kind of a whole life
philosophy lesson uh take it for and
look i don't want to pretend like i'm in
like
a permanent state of zen or nirvana
either i have my moments but
my coping mechanism is definitely to
kind of get more grounded centered
not fixate too much on my persona and
realize that most of the stuff resolves
itself and we have only so much time on
this planet
uh let's not spend that time obsessing
or feeling low about ourselves if we can
avoid it if we can avoid it i know and
there's many cases where it's much
harder and
uh and and if it's in a tough situation
definitely seek help because you know
that's the other thing i would say
if you're in a really bad situation uh
or even a medium bad situation because
sometimes it's worse than you might
realize
uh fine find help no don't be afraid to
ask for help or embarrassed
um so
from facebook selena chang what are some
problems in the world that high school
students can help solve by creating
their own initiatives
well well celine i gotta say there's an
as time goes by fast when you're giving
advice
uh so uh there's there's a ton that you
could do right now i
you know there's never been more
opportunities for people your age
outlets to help the world you know we
live in a world and you know
there's a lot of positives and there's a
lot of negatives people talk about about
things like social media and
youtube and all that but there's a lot
of positives as well like you can create
content
that can help teach people you can
create content that builds awareness
you could create software that helps
solve
real problems for folks you know in this
coveted world
it surfaced all sorts of new problems
but the
the the other side of the problem coin
is that these are opportunities for
things that need to be fixed
you know i talked earlier in the covid
crisis about creating mechanisms to help
elderly in your neighborhood
get the things they need so that they
don't have to be exposed um
there could be mechanisms you know
everyone is rethinking about
how they do everything right now uh from
how they get their groceries to how
you know what they do for entertainment
to how they stay connected with friends
and family
these are all huge opportunities i've
always said
you know people focus on so many things
in the day to day but they often don't
focus on some of the most important
things like the memories of their family
and all of that i wanted to start a
project that i haven't had time for i've
been trying to convince every young
person i can talk to to start it i would
be a customer if you started this
of uh doing really comprehensive
interviews and
and documenting the life narratives of
essentially everyone
in my extended family because how
powerful would that be you know i had an
uncle who passed away recently
and you know i i kick myself that i
didn't
you know sit down with him for a few
days and just record like every little
detail about his life history
one to help remember him but also those
those stories are going to get lost
and if you think about it those stories
those memories are the most valuable
thing that my family has but no one's
thinking about that
and i want to do that with you know i
wish i did it with that uncle i want to
do it with his wife i want to do with my
mom i want to do it with
everybody you know uh the my my wife two
of her grandparents are still alive i
tell her every day like
we got to get them on zoom and record
their life story
you know one day we're just going to
kick ourselves for not doing it but i
could imagine a service that does
something like that
kind of like what you know storycorps
and npr but on on steroids so it can
like
it can document your entire family uh i
i i would pay for that i think that
would be more valuable than anything
else that i could i could do so anyway
that's just a
there's a lot that could be worked on
right now and maybe at some point we
could we could have an ama where we
brainstorm
uh either not-for-profit or business
ideas uh
so i'll end on that looks like we're
almost out of time let me see
um well i'm gonna answer one more
question just cause it's a good one
there's a lot of good questions here i
have about two more minutes from youtube
justjit singh
is asking i was always told my grades
decide my future
is success without good grades possible
i think
saying your grades decide your future is
a strong statement i think grades
might influence your future and and they
definitely good grades can open up
opportunity and
not so good grades unfortunately can
sometimes close opportunities
that's why i've been a big fan of
mastery learning because in mastery
learning essentially your grade is never
permanent you can always
improve yourself if you're at a c level
today that just means you haven't
learned it fully yet you can get to a b
or an a so definitely have that mindset
i would say
earlier in your life your actual grades
are more feedback for you and your
family
so if you're you know in in elementary
and middle school
what really matters that you eventually
really master the material so that when
you get to high school and college
uh which you know i wish they were
mastery learning as well or were more
mastery learning but that's where the
stakes unfortunately on in today's world
get a little bit higher
but i've seen time and time again
there's many folks you know don't be
down on yourself
if you're making your best effort you
know go back to that software action
if you're taking the action you're
saying look i'm doing what i think i
need to do
to the best of my ability i'm making the
effort i'm stepping out of my comfort
zone
i'm willing to try things that seem a
little bit difficult for me but stick at
them
then the chips fall where they do you
know the grades are what they are
and then um you know what i've seen is
there are folks where
uh you know the grades can bring the
opportunity but there's also folks with
great grades but
you know they're they they don't know
what to do with it or the opportunity or
life
kind of throws them off balance one way
or the other and and that's tough and i
know folks with
you know not so great grades uh who've
done incredible things
so definitely don't think that your
grades determine your destiny and
definitely don't let that be a source of
being down on yourself because then it
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
if your grades if you're doing your best
effort
and then you're still not getting the
grades you want and then you think that
that says something about yourself it's
going to affect your self-esteem
which is just going to become a
self-fulfilling prophecy where you're
going to be less confident
if anything the people that i've seen
most successful in life are people who
have invested themselves making sure
they have
some set of really valuable skills
people who uh and and they and they and
they are willing to kind of put
themselves out there into the world
and sometimes fail you know sometimes be
embarrassed sometimes be told no to
sometimes being rejected
but they're constantly developing
themselves they're constantly putting
themselves out in the world
and they you know we all have our low
points i have my low points
but you know you you you're able to kind
of
pick yourself up from them and hopefully
uh put you know
and and fight the next battle uh i think
puts you in a pretty good position
regardless of what your grades are
uh so anyway i'll leave you all there
take everything i say with a grain of
salt i am not like a paid
like anything well i for in terms of
advice
um so you know but hopefully hopefully
it's helpful but these are really great
questions uh thanks everyone and
i think it's next week let me see it's
gonna be thursday actually
we're gonna have uh jeff rosen who i
consider a good friend
from the national constitution center it
is a constitution day
so we're going to talk about the united
states constitution which is also
always and i'm not saying this
sarcastically i actually generally read
it because i love learning
it is actually an amazing thing to talk
about because we we
we talk about it in in popular culture a
lot
but when you actually read it and i
encourage everyone to read it and digest
it it's quite
readable i think it's a very powerful
document so anyway i look forward to
seeing you all on thursday as we talk
about the u.s constitution
you